so you were in and out of working for
Safeway warehouse job while writing
these scripts yeah yeah what I worked I
worked in the store for three years and
then warehouse for years afterward after
that and so when did you finally quit
that job when I sold the script of
paramount literally they they they
wanted the script that got passed from
the actress all the way through ended up
at a production company on the Paramount
lot and they asked if they could fly me
and put me up in a hotel and discuss my
script and I said yeah I think that
sounds okay and they bought the script
and basically I made two years of
safeway money off that sale and then
went you know went back and gave my
six-week notice and you know because I I
was going to give a two-week notice they
go look bill we really need to stay for
a little longer okay I could do that and
you know because it was in the bag you
know
so I basically did that and did a little
bit of rewrite work while I was still
working in Safeway on that script and
then came back you know basically moved
to Los Angeles after that I sold the
script and didn't need to do then I
squandered my two years worth of you
know forklift justing salary on not done
writing scripts but not doing much to
actually make connections so that was my
screw-up I didn't make connections so
there's the there's the thing once you
sell your script you still gonna make
connections is that all the writers sort
of introversion yeah absolutely
absolutely absolutely for me heaven is
sitting in a room alone typing and so I
got I got my heaven for two years and
then after that it's like I'm running
out of money I got to do something and
then I sort of went into semi panic mode
I'd gone to the American film market
every year and because I again actually
because of people I knew that you know
had known about it and said hey let's go
to American film market what's that so I
found out about it so I went to American
film market that year as I was running
out of money and basically said I must
sell a script in these 12 days or
however many days it was and did put
together a project that
then was doomed kind of it eventually
got made but it was called treacherous
and set it up at hemdale who'd made the
first Terminator movie and in fact I
actually pitched Terminator 2 the TV
show at one point in time because they
liked me and you know I wanted to have
arms warts and anger say I'll be back
after this commercial message but so I
set it up with hemdale hemdale then went
bankrupt the script got bounced around
and ended up at Universal Pictures
Universal Pictures our executive there
was putting it together and then died in
a plane wreck and the his the the person
that took over his space said I'm not
making any of that guy's movies so the
script was again bouncing around and
landed at ITC which was a British
company that had sort of were selling
the rights to their British TV shows to
Lord Lu grade was making movies in here
they were also selling the rights to
their TV shows but they had like an
office in Los Angeles and they had a
deal with 20th Century Fox to make
movies for Cinemax and HBO and so I sort
of did found that home and then nobody
died and you know it got made and it got
made though at a much reduced budget
than it originally was we originally had
Mickey Rourke at hemdale when Mickey
work was somebody and and Brian Dennehy
as the sidekick so it was like gonna be
a great movie and then ended up being
see Thomas Howell and Adam Baldwin and
Tia Carrere which was still you know
okay for but not what it could have been
you